[Music]
bring it to the runway bring it to the
runway runway run run run
runway bring it to the runway runway run
run run way let's talk about the season
yeah
favourite fashion moment of the season
are you is that a real question the
sponge dress girl
I'm not joking this one dress was the
greatest did anybody get that my
favourite fashion moment had to have
been the evil twin challenge I think not
the to my own home but Billa dude to do
I mean my my lavender and mint look was
just like perfect pastel fabulousness
and then my evil cheetah butcher lady
French woman Dita Von Teese thing was
just you know it just came off so great
on the runway this is in the top 10
outfits I've ever seen walk down this
runway for sure oh my goodness I was
gobsmacked gobsmacked it was you know
I'm very honored to receive such a
compliment and you know maybe bruised
you know memory might be a little cloudy
from the past ten seasons but I will
take the compliment nonetheless because
the best favorite fashion moment of the
season would be anything aquario wore
[Music]
aquario with the hat that's the bunny
[Music]
oh my god
up wearing and mermaid-like come on I
said really just oil-filled that's
really rude
to see her do such a nice homage to Gaga
but still put a little spin on it so
make it so cool and sleek and editorial
really really really gorgeous loved it
that looked at the whole time
guess who's finally decided to crash the
party
[Music]
my favorite fashion moment was my
feather gown that I wore in episode 3
the black Kuro the black feathers I am
giving you my best evil wing here to
rule the world that was you know so so
spectacular and so well detailed and so
well executed I mean I think my favorite
fashion moment was myself coming out as
the big baby making a body positive
statement I think it was beautiful my
favorite fashion moment of the season
was definitely Monique heart because
Monique heart made the most incredible
Queen of Hearts dress for the drag on a
dime challenge
she is historic is stunning I think it's
gonna go down in history as one of the
greats
with people that have a good taste it's
incredible yeah
I'm biased but I will say I like coming
out in a clear bathing suit with my ass
crack out and all that stuff that was a
bold one for me favorite fashion moment
the Barbies in the arm flowers
[Applause]